how's it going raise money today yeah
we're gonna try out digital Barbie
makeup it sounds so dumb but a lot of
you bros requested this one so I want at
least try it out I don't even know what
is this Barbie
did you dollar makeover the [ __ ] that
you bros telling me to play let's do
this oh my god this is so dumb oh oh you
got my face up close how's it going
there we go
I'm so fast no no yeah
[Music]
you're just jealous cuz I'm Way more
prettier than you
what else hmm oh my god so [ __ ] the cow
anus has is strong with this one I am
the most fabulous girl in the whole
world I mean but this is a future bras
this is the most amazing thing I have
ever seen in my life
oh my god give me back watch look at my
cheeks they're so orange am i beautiful
am i beautiful yet hello oh my god oh my
god what am i doing Mimolette oh hello
alright let's do a picture you get a
picture right oh okay here we go
there we go that went great so pretty
Wow such improvement I can put this on
me okay that's that's pretty cute I
guess
oh god not so close please stop it for
the love of God okay I can add a bunch
of cigar features that's pretty cute can
add a car sticker because that's also
very cute I can add text too oh that's
awesome let's do that there we go I'll
probably use this as my resume in the
future I can't get over how beautiful I
am
hey this if you saw me now you wouldn't
be talking okay yeah me you wouldn't be
talking
you wouldn't be god dammit stop it that
is pretty pretty I'm having way too much
fun with this
this app is seriously made for like
eight-year-old girls and I'm probably
enjoying it more than they are but none
of them look as fabulous as I do so it
doesn't matter put a son in that [ __ ]
put some random @ true there we go oh my
god haters back off I think this is one
my favorite oh my god is the best
picture of all time there we go save
that [ __ ] amazing well this app has
certainly changed my life it's free so
you can go right now and fabulous
yourself for real for free how amazing
is it to live in the future thank you
for liking and commenting on this video
Bros and thanks for hanging out with me
today even though I haven't slept this
night I don't know if you noticed but my
dog is Penn State my head my dog Maya
has been sick so it's I haven't slept
but that's okay thanks for hanging out
with me today rose and stay awesome
Bella finished